hi I'm Cobie Smulders and I play
dexedrine Perry oz on Stumptown my name
is Jake Johnson and I played great
I am Michael Healy and I play detective
Hoffman my name is Cole I play ezel I'm
Camryn Manheim I play Bobby
cosgrove I'm tanto Cardinal I play
Siouxland Blackbird hi I'm Adrian
Martinez and I played cookie and this is
about our firsts first role you really
wanted but went to someone else there's
been so many I was driving down to do a
test for The Aviator yeah starring
Leonardo DiCaprio I got rear-ended the
car was totaled I was in a neck brace I
was stuck in Medford Oregon and I could
not go to the test I got a very close to
playing the bad guy on The Sitter which
was a Jonah Hill movie a comedy that
David Gordon Green was directing the me
out to New York and I read for it in his
apartment on a Saturday and I thought
like yeah I'm in his house hmm
this is happening yeah we're shooting on
Tuesday Jake EJ is here I'm here I'm in
the house right here and then Monday
Tuesday came in I didn't get it and Sam
Rockwell's got the job and I mean they
did agree there's not nobody is the role
in 2 fast 2 furious
I auditioned for the role of Ted which
Ludacris ended up playing what's
interesting and what hurts about it is
that ted has gone on to be in I don't
know 9 I love The Fast and Furious
movies and I have not so you know that
that one that one still hurts a little
bit first big audition this one Sun town
this is a great one that'd be your first
yes I know mine was obviously the
practice the worst audition I
ever had in my life and as I was getting
up to leave I noticed he had a cribbage
board I just said David do you play
cribbage he kind of scooted up and he
went you know I do but I don't think you
want to go there with me so I said I
challenge you to a duel by blues I walk
out I never see you yet but if I went I
walk out with the script obviously I got
the role and there was a movie I did I
had a horrible experience on but it was
done I literally prayed and I said dear
God you really have to give me a sign if
you want me to stay in this business the
next thing you know it was auditioning
for this movie focus and I booked it and
I thought ok I got the same I tried to
go and audition for a movie called death
hunt and I go into the audition hall and
there's all these girls sitting around
in their very Brown makeup and there are
all white girls with their turquoise
jewelry with all of their Indian stuff
they got the Bell first incorrect rumor
you read about yourself it was on the
bathroom stall in elementary school and
it said Cobie Smulders has a big butt
that's not true oh yeah why did you
write a blast I did an interview it was
when new girl first started they said
what's one thing you don't like about
being recognized and I said jokingly I
get hugged by a lot of men and I'm not a
touchy guy and so it's a lot of like
male men's ears touching my ears when we
do a hug it was in passing and it was
not something I thought about
and then on Yahoo I was checking my
email and it said new girl actor two
male fans don't touch me and I thought
like ooh
Zooey screwed you can't see them and
they're gonna hate you
midway through after the comments of how
much they hated me I was like oh that's
a rumor they didn't quite mean that yeah
there was a rumor that
Sierra and I had hooked up in a New York
club one night and I had never met her
before ever in my life how come you're
not being honest right now yeah
I'm being totally sure the weird
different guy on camera give the guy off
camera yeah okay thanks question the
weird thing is is that with me first
time you were starstruck it's happening
alright first 20 years starstruck sorry
I keep snorting my first thought Greg
was I met AC green he's so tall and I'm
I'm and that sort is whenever you're
gonna have to tell me who AC green knows
if he's a Abascal player he would do
playboy Lakers I was doing the practice
I got invited to a very sheshe Hollywood
party
I had one minute I was talking to Meryl
Streep I couldn't even believe I was
talking to her and all of a sudden my
eyes started to glaze over and I was
like Meryl I cannot concentrate on a
thing you were saying right now Mick
Jagger is standing right behind you oh I
would start start once and twice all in
the same moment and then she was like
really to my life to to my right so even
Meryl Streep was starstruck do any of
the guys know who Lee Marvin she was
stepping up these stairs and then he
stops and the Rocky Mountains are behind
him and I say you look like the Rocky
Mountains didn't say oh that was a table
read for a movie called Morning Glory
and Harrison Ford was there I walked up
to its excuse me mr. Farley I just want
you to know you were really important to
me growing up and seeing your movies and
I just kind of like leaned forward a bit
humbled to sit I said thank you so much
that means a lot to me any other Saved
by the Bell fans in the house Zack
Morris I saw him at a party at a
Hollywood party and my husband kind of
was like gotta go and like say hi and I
just totally froze I think pretty much
left out like I left five minutes later
because I just like I quitting I
couldn't get past it because I was very
much in love yeah I had a big crush on
DJ Tanner from foe yeah you could say
anything to Zack fallin out I'm a big
fan and I think you're really talented
and thank you for years of entertainment
[Applause]
I got it out of my system I'm ready to
go back to my marriage okay my first
time was Magic Johnson I remember I was
on a red carpet for a movie he had
produced called brown sugar and I was at
the premiere and I was answering
questions and the biggest hand in the
world came into my view and I was like
what what is that and I looked over and
the next thing I looked up and he's the
most massive man I had ever seen and
instead of shaking his hand I literally
hugged him I got an MBA one that doesn't
have a cool ending I went to a game in
Tyson Chandler I was a big fan of from
Chicago we drafted him I followed his
career and my buddy Eric Edelstein who
was an actor snuck us into the family
section after the game and I had an
out-of-body experience because Tyson
Chandler was standing next to me I swear
on my life I don't remember doing it I
was not conscious of it but my buddy
Eric goes hey and my hand was right at
like the small of his know her back and
I was going to touch him but it wasn't
aggressive it was just like wow I'm the
ash - I'm playing games for so long I
know your whole story you're here I was
just going like this and he was like you
have to see if he was real like it is
there was no thought but it was a gentle
touch
[Music]